all right guys
bang bang i've got jed here thank you so
much for doing this sir
yeah thanks for having me for sure let's
just get started with your background
you've got this kind of very extensive
technology
driven background where did you get
started in the business and technology
world and how do we eventually get to
uh stellar yeah i mean i've been
programming
for a really long time probably since
you know third or fourth grade
uh yeah and um i i've always been
interested in kind of like distributed
systems like the the first kind of
successful thing i did was this program
called e donkey 2000 which was
sort of like bittorrent it was like a
file sharing thing um this peer-to-peer
network
um that was pretty popular in like 2000
around there in 2001
um and then kind of after that was
winding down
um you know i i i was like working on
some other project and then i came
across bitcoin and got super excited
about it
so got really into crypto because it was
kind of in line with stuff i've already
was working on and uh you know my
general ethos
got it and do you remember the first
time you ever heard about bitcoin or
like what your thought was when you saw
it
yeah it was summer of 2010
uh there was like the first article like
there was a slashdart article about it
and um you know i haven't i haven't even
read slashdot in years
but but i was just kind of looking for
another project and kind of like looking
around and i came across it now i was
like uh
really surprised that somebody had was
able to solve this problem because
it didn't seem possible before before i
learned about bitcoin i think a lot of
people had a summer reaction
um and got super excited about it and
that's kind of all i thought about the
next
you know well really years but but uh
but yeah definitely
definitely there's like a few like that
month after which that's what i kind of
working on but and where does mount gox
come from because you basically
acquired mount cox i think the url but
it was really for magic cars like tell
us that story
oh yes so i i had so basically i
read about bitcoin in like you know
summer of 2010
uh kind of immediately i was like well i
gotta want to play around with this i
want to buy
some of these things and there wasn't
really a good way to do that at the time
so then i said okay fine i'll just build
an exchange
like it was pretty clear that it needed
that kind of thing um
and uh built that over the course of
like two weeks
uh and i you know this is so early in in
bitcoin's history it was like very
there's like maybe 2 000 people on
bitcoin talk which is like the extent of
people that knew about it at all
so it's just very unclear what it was
going to happen with it or what it's
going to do so i i didn't want to like
i i had a domain sitting around this
mount cox domain which i'd used for a
project years ago
and it was just kind of idle so like
okay if i almost call it this and and
do this thing um so that's where the
name came from and
and how that came together got it and so
when you're building
you know kind of the exchange you're
looking at bitcoin you can't stop
thinking about it what was your thought
process was it like hey maybe this thing
grows into
you know a couple million dollars of
volume or was it like this is gonna be
the next global reserve currency like
kind of how bullish were you or what was
your thought process at the time
um so i thought like i thought it was an
awesome idea
and would have loved to see it like take
off into the world and like a huge
it seemed kind of like a long shot that
that would happen just because it was so
small and like
the the the the idea of like the
audacity of like saying hey we're gonna
make this
new currency that everyone's gonna adopt
over the world it's pretty huge right
so so uh you know i thought it you know
these things only kind of
worked to the extent that other people
kind of buy into them and like
then like also agree that this would be
a cool thing and it just seemed like it
was one
going to be like this kind of internet
thing that maybe it would grow over like
years and years but i had no idea it
would grow this quickly right so
um uh although i wanted it to but
but but it just seemed like it would
take a lot longer for people to kind of
wrap their heads around it
understand that this is a good concept
like there was obviously like this group
of people
that that kind of got it and understood
why the world needed this like
alternative to fiat currency but
but it was just unclear to me that that
was as widespread as it actually turned
out to be
right so so uh i i think me and i think
i mean most people
like were hopeful but but kind of like
cautiously optimistic i guess like they
just
thought this would take a lot longer and
and you know it was
you know uh it was it was cool to see
like how
how fast it got adopted like widely so
absolutely
and so basically you end up selling
mount gox um
ripple stellar kind of how do we get to
from mount gox
to uh stellar yeah so like i said i kind
of just did
i kind of made mac ox just to learn
bitcoin essentially just like
play around with it and you know i
wanted it was something that the
ecosystem clearly needed and it would be
a cool project
but i never really intended to run it
long term so like as it kind of started
to get traction i realized it was
starting to take up more and more of my
time like it's not something that i
really wanted to think about all the
time like it's it's you know it's not uh
it's not oh well i mean i just generally
like to work on like harder like
um you know problems i guess so so yeah
so i sold it to that guy in japan
unfortunately he ended up being pretty
confident
and you know that you guys can all look
up that history if you don't already
know
but um uh and then i was thinking about
other
like basically i i've always thought
bitcoin is this awesome idea but it was
kind of bothered by the
mining aspect of it like it's it uses
obviously uses like a ton of resources
and if there's a way to
solve this consensus problem without
doing that uh it would be
it would be great right so i kind of
like started thinking about other ways
to like
solve like the double spin problem which
is what mining and bitcoin does
is like solve this consensus issue um
and came up with the idea that kind of
led to ripple so
um so i moved to california and with the
intention of like starting ripple and
and like you know found some people work
on it with me uh
you know we were working out for a while
then i brought in uh someone to be ceo
and then that ended we ended up not
seeing eye to eye and there was like
some drama there and so i mentioned left
ripple the intent of kind of just doing
something else entirely uh but the the
original idea and premise and like the
reason why i wanted to do ripple in the
first place or like what like crypto in
the first place was still there and it's
like
kind of hard to get away from and so
then i set up stellar with kind of like
the intent to just kind of make this
network the way that
that that uh i think is most beneficial
for the world so
got it so let's start with just kind of
a 101 of what is stellar
how does it work and when you describe
it to people who know nothing about
you know cryptocurrencies or anything
like like what's that uh description
yeah so um well so the basic problem
that we're trying to solve is if you
know anything about
uh like the financial infrastructure
today the way the way money moves around
the planet it's very much pre-internet
right there's all these different
financial networks you know there's like
uh you know ach and sepa and swift and
like mobile money things and
you know in pesa and all these kind of
things and they don't interoperate right
they they all have their different
standards and and if you want to send
money from paypal to
you know some mobile money thing in
southeast asia you just can't do it
right
they're just not they just don't
communicate uh and this is all this
situation is like very much like
the way that the way the world was
before the internet and
and uh the idea behind buying stellar is
just how do you
make this interoperable layer where all
these things can communicate with each
other right so
not just in financial networks but
different currencies right so if you're
holding
you know pesos in mexico and you want to
send you know five dollars to somebody
and like
uh you know italy like that's really not
even possible today right
in the affordable way right so so uh
stellar's a way to to do that right it
just it just allows you to use any
currency at any financial institution
and seamlessly and effortlessly send
anybody else in the world right so
that's that's kind of the goal
and the way we do that is by leveraging
this this uh
innovation that that bitcoin uh came up
with which is is like this distributed
ledger that
everyone can see but no one can change
arbitrarily right there's like certain
rules that have to be followed and
there's this consensus mechanism that
that that is adhered to and then
uh and this ledger is updated over time
right and so the beauty of that is that
there's no
um central part of you maybe your
listeners know all this stuff but
but but there's no there's no person
that you have to like
uh absolutely trust uh so like if you
have two financial institutions that
don't necessarily know each other
now they can go through this distributed
ledger uh to be able to transact even
though
they maybe not trust each other and
maybe just don't have a formal
relationship with each other
uh and it's so it's it's kind of the
like the core like blockchain ideas what
kind of unlocks this ability to be able
to make this
this internet level protocol for for
payments right and so
so that's what seller had so like
basically to be kind of less abstract
about it so
what it allows you to do is hold any
kind of currency you can hold like
dollars euros
you know bitcoin anything any anything
you want can be tokenized onto the
network
uh and it's sort of you know you know
stellar was launched
like i think over six years ago now or
maybe about six years ago
um and then that was like the premise of
the idea and like now we're kind of
seeing that
it's like stable points like people have
kind of got the point that that it's
useful to have
um you know representations of money
that you're used to using
in these same digital networks right you
want to be able to have your
you know us dollars operate with your
ethereum operate with your like yen or
whatever like these things all need to
kind of be in the same
ecosystem and that unlocks all this kind
of power right and so
that's the idea behind sellers that you
can represent any kind of value and you
can trade this value
amongst each other so it's almost like
what you're doing is you're basically
making the
technology interoperable and then where
the competition plays out is that like
the monetary policy layer let's say for
currencies right is
the differentiation is no longer in like
hey i have dollars on my wallet i have
to physically go
to like a currency exchanger at the
airport to exchange it for some other
currency
now i just everything's interoperable
click of a button i can move in between
these reduce the friction
but at that monetary policy layer
there's obviously differences and so i
can make my decisions based on
non-technological barriers to some
degree yeah i mean
yeah i mean you could imagine a world
where you know it's not even currency
but maybe like
you know if regulations start to allow
it's like you could have like shares of
apple or shares of stock and then like
when you go
to spend they just get seamlessly
converted into whatever right
so you know like it allows you to just
do very different things than what
what's done today and gives people like
a lot more flexibility
uh like right now we're one of the
things one of the big things we're
working on is
this dollar savings project where it's
basically like a mobile
uh consumer app uh it allows people in
places with really high inflation like
say argentina
to be able to save their money in
dollars right and so that that
that's like this really awesome use of
this technology that that wasn't really
possible before so
so uh things like that are just like
super exciting to us got it
and so basically like how's it going
right like how do you think about the
uh adoption kind of the development and
evolution of
stellar to where we are today is this
going well going better than you
expected not going so well
how do you kind of measure that sure
yeah i mean it's going really well
i mean it's a it's a really hard problem
and i think we see this with all
throughout all of crypto is that you
know there's a lot of
interest and a lot of hype around it and
a lot of people like it but if when you
go and look like how
people actually using this in the real
world that's pretty still very nascent
right there's still not a lot of like
you know you don't have like a million
users using it every day for like
actual transactions things like that
right and i think it's because
uh all of these things depend really
heavily on network effects like you need
lots of people in the world
to be kind of on board before they're
useful right so particularly something
like like stellar where it's all about
payments right so
if if you can only pay to a certain
number of people in the world then your
payment system isn't that useful so
so you kind of have to get over this
network effect hurdle and and
and that's what's kind of made it take
so long for i think
all of crypto in general right so um but
but where we are now is
uh you know we have a pretty good uh
idea and route for like
how to like get a beachhead into these
network effects how to make things
useful for people
uh before there is a big network and so
that's the main thing we're working on
we've seen
we've seen adoption go up quite a bit
over the last year like this
has been a really big year for us uh the
team has grown a lot
uh you know i think uh you know there's
more more accounts on the network
there's way more transactions we've had
i i think i don't go to stats but i
think like 90 of our operations over the
lifetime of history have been in this
last year like it's just
the popularity is just increasing like
quite a bit
um so uh but so so all those things
things are going great i mean i think
they're still obviously we're not done
there's still a lot of work to do
but uh but yeah we're definitely the
right tractor got it and how do you look
at yourself
and kind of all these other smart
contract platforms you know mention
stable coins earlier let's take ethereum
for example there's lots of activity
there
is this a world where there's
coexistence uh kind of at the end is it
there's got to be a winner take all
just how do you look at a competitive
landscape or just other platforms that
people can use
yeah so i mean i think in general a lot
of these
you know it crypto all kind of gets
lumped into this one bucket but but it's
i don't i don't think it's like winner
take all at all like i mean it's
probably winner take all in like certain
niches but
but these things are all solving very
different problems like the problem
bitcoin is solving is very different
from what three i'm solving which is
very different from what stellar solving
right so
like like ethereum is basically like
this kind of uh you know generic
universal like computation thing uh that
that
isn't it isn't tailored for payment
specifically and you're obviously using
it for that whereas
stellar is designed to fill this like
very kind of
narrow niche when it's not narrow
because everyone sends payments but but
it but it's a specific one right so it's
like
it's it's uh like definitely in the
future multiple of these things will
exist
uh i think i think the hope is that
stellar will be very good for like
crossbow payments and like sending
you know representing other kinds of uh
value like
like the whole stable point thing works
way way better on stellar just because
it's designed to do that
um whereas ethereum would be like you
know like you're never going to make
like a prediction market
on stellar right whereas you can do that
on theory right there's just
different things that they could be done
got it and so when we kind of fast
forward here we say
okay uh we're basically giving people
the tools to build all kinds of stuff
that they want to build
and you're really focused i think on
making sure those tools work and
operate correctly how do you think about
where we're headed
right you know 10 years from now is this
a world where every stock bond currency
commodity is digitized and it's on these
networks and like
it's kind of the you know bitcoinization
of the world and tokenization of the
world
uh or is it something that maybe isn't
as audacious
in terms of uh you know kind of that
final state or
next decade or so yeah um so i mean i do
think
like uh yeah that most things will have
like some digital representation i mean
it just makes
it just makes so much more sense and
it's easier and like
you know if you've ever send payments
with cryptocurrency you know pay for
something online then you have to go use
a credit card it's just so annoying you
have to get
all the details and all this kind of
stuff like it's just so much nicer right
so
so i i do think that that uh that we're
going to move that direction
and um you know i think uh
there is some limit to it and there will
still like people
like the general like population
probably doesn't want to deal with their
own secret key and it's probably not
safe for them to think like that so
there will have to be like
solutions around that that'll end up
looking uh
not that different than what we have
like you know there'll be things like a
global venmo
things like that but but but uh but the
user experience will be very similar to
what they're used to now or just be
it'll
have more capabilities than what they
can do today right and so i think all of
that is it's really good but
but um but yeah i mean i think it will
be um
we're still a long way to go like i said
for for it to be like
where there's like millions of people
using crypto every day for their
everyday lives but
but uh i think we will get there in the
next years
and what do you think the response from
the incumbents are right so like
basically what you're building what you
know folks are building with stable
coins on ethereum what bitcoin is being
built
everyone is kind of under attack if
you're an incumbent
from all these technological uh upstarts
or
really challengers right and so uh put
aside for a second who wins who doesn't
win you know kind of
how it plays out from the challenger
side just if you're an incumbent you've
got to feel like
you know the technology industry is
coming for us what do you think is kind
of the rational response from them and
is it something where you know some of
them adopt and or
adapt and end up surviving uh while some
die or
are we looking at potentially like a
full-blown disruption of the entire
industry and basically none of them can
keep up
and and there's entirely new players
yeah i mean i mean anytime there's like
some large techno
technological change there there is this
you know there are some companies that
can handle it there's some that can't
right like you know even if you look at
like
the internet coming along you know now
that there used to be tons of bookstores
now there's just amazon right so like
you know i think i think it'll be some
something in between uh
just like you know in 10 years there's
like none of the companies today will be
around anything like that but i think i
think
some of them will adapt and like you see
that already like you see like
you know like paypal is now accepting
bitcoin like squares obviously very like
crypto forward things like this so so
some companies are
are realizing that this is the way that
things are going to be in the future and
they're moving that direction
uh so i i think you know and some are
just moving much more slowly but
but uh but but i think it is inevitable
and
just like any big change like there's
gonna be but there's gonna be some
people that get it and there's just
maybe some that
that don't right so um you know i mean
like paypal for instance they uh
they banned like i used to take paypal
at mount gox and they like they banned
me for life for having a paypal account
and now they're they're accepting
bitcoin so
so i don't know they've obviously
changed some some point
ten years so are you trying to uh get
your account back or is that a focus of
yours
uh no not really i don't need a paid
account at this point
absolutely and so when you think about
kind of the
the world as we're evolving here um a
lot of times i just think about like
where you spend your time and obviously
you're spending majority if not all of
your
time on stellar what do you think about
some of the other things that are going
on
is this a world where you're like hey
look you know bitcoin stellar
and then tokenization of assets or like
how do you kind of just think about the
things that you're personally interested
in
and where you spend your time yeah i
mean obviously there's just a ton going
on in
crypto space in general it's just very
hard to like keep track of it all and
you know frankly i don't spend that much
time thinking about projects outside of
stellar like i mean there's so much to
do with
with the stellar network that that uh
that kind of takes up all my
all my bandwidth i mean there's uh
so yes i mean i think the things that
are interesting for me
are just again this idea that that
that the world needs is interoperable
layer between all these things and like
how we make that possible and and
how do you bootstrap that network and
that that's mainly what i spend time
thinking about
and just and kind of some stuff about
like how like once you
once you start to get scale like how do
you make these networks
um go much further than they can today
because you know
they're uh all of these things have
pretty bad
scaling properties if you compare them
to just like a database that you can
like
shard and all this kind of stuff so you
you have to come up with like methods
for like how this is going to work
long term and so that's that's what
we're spending a lot of time doing now
it's like you know
like what like what like how does this
work in the win condition
like i mean how do you actually get like
millions and millions of people on these
networks
so um yeah so we have some ideas around
that that's what we're
spending a lot of time got it uh there
was recently this new piece of
legislation that was put forward called
the stable
act and it essentially you know a very
broad generalization says you can't
create a stable coin unless you've got a
federal bank charter right
for all intents and purposes um and
there's a lot of controversy around this
it feels like you know some people in
the political sphere
uh think this is the greatest idea ever
and they're gonna you know work
diligently to get it approved
there's a lot of people i think in the
crypto community that say this is way
off base and kind of exposes their lack
of understanding of a lot of this
how do you think about it and kind of is
there anything that you guys are doing
from stellar i saw you guys put out an
announcement
or kind of a statement just talk through
that piece of legislation
sure yeah um yeah we put out a blog post
about it that kind of goes into it i
mean i i i
appreciate the uh idea behind it
what i assume is the idea is that they
want to like uh you know protect
consumers from
from like you know losing all their
money right which is you know what's
something that obviously needs to happen
but
but i mean this this particular piece of
legislation seems like
like poorly crafted i mean it seems like
it would ban things like
like venmo originally i mean that's a
digital currency that that that wasn't a
bank i mean i think paypal's bank now
but
but originally when demo started you
know that would have been disallowed
right and
that's just like terrible for innovation
and it all just lets you do is just have
these these people that are banks these
all
that they there's there's no motivation
for them to improve their situation
or consumers like like the consumers
ultimately will hurt by that because
like
there's not new innovation and and they
just become like this like
kind of calcified dinosaurs and there's
no there's no
there's nothing that they're competing
against which which is like what drives
all of this improvement for
for consumers right so it just seems
like a very bad approach
uh to me so yeah yeah and to me what was
so interesting about
when they you know announced the
legislation or the proposed legislation
was basically saying like hey we're
doing this for financial inclusion like
the banks have always preyed on
everybody so instead of allowing
uh kind of free market competition and
innovation to take hold
we're basically going to just put a
bunch of bureaucracy and regulatory
hurdles in the way
which seemed counter to the position
they were taking
yeah for sure i don't see how this would
help financial inclusion at all i mean
like
all of that stuff is going to be done by
someone who actually cares about the
problem and is not a bank
and wants and needs some token that he
can you know send around to these people
and
and that's just this just prohibits that
so yeah yeah
and how do you think about crypto in
light of financial inclusion right i
think
it's much easier to kind of understand
it in the most extreme cases where
people
have no access to banking in some third
world country and like hey now with an
internet connection
but just maybe in the more developed
world like where do you see that
happening is it affecting
uh a certain portion of the population
like you know the bottom fifty percent
of americans
uh is it something where nope this is
gonna be pervasive and everybody
regardless of socioeconomic status are
gonna end up using this stuff
just talk through that financial
inclusion component and kind of where
you see a lot of this technology fitting
sure yeah i mean we've spent a lot of
time working uh on financial inclusion
at sdf um i mean that was kind of our
one of our original thrusts and like
you know we've always thought that this
is going to take off in the developing
world
much more quicker than the developer
world just because
uh you know because the financial
infrastructure is just so much weaker
there right and
there's it's in the same way that like
you know cell phone adoption happened
first or like much quicker in like
places like philippines and indonesia
where people didn't have landlines
already right so
you can kind of just leapfrog it if
you're not if you're not beholden to the
old system
but i think i think crypto and like
definitely stellar uh
just help the financial inclusion story
tremendously because they make they make
it where
uh they just reduce uh take out a lot of
friction from the system
one of the things that was like kind of
causing financial like exclusion i guess
before is because it's just very
expensive for banks to actually
serve these people right so like if they
couldn't make a certain amount per
customer then it just
it just wasn't feasible for them to do
it because uh because
you know their systems were just like
old and cumbersome and it was actually
expensive for them to
help these people whereas you know if
you have like uh
you know if you have like like some
mobile wallet that's built on something
like stellar
you can have some digital dollar in
there and you can pay people
and you can you know you can have it
connected to like you know like
savings and like interest bearing things
stuff like that right
and all that becomes essentially like
this very lightweight bank account and
it's like super cheap the service
and uh you know can can uh you know
connect people to the wider financial
world which is what you want to do to
like financially include people so
ultimately should be very beneficial for
people not just in like you know places
like nigeria but like
places in the us as well right so that's
wrong
and it's the thought process that
eventually you know take an average
uh consumer whether the united states or
or developing
uh country the all of their interaction
with the financial system will be done
through
algorithms and networks and kind of
decentralized type applications
or do you think that there still will be
this like coexistence hybrid world where
uh maybe i have a traditional bank
account at a centralized entity but then
i also use some of these other
pieces of technology to earn more
interest or kind of
you know send money and remittances or
whatever it is
yeah i mean i think i think it will be
some sort of hybrid i mean like i was
saying before it's like i think it'll be
i don't think people ever get to the
point where they want to secure people
in general will want to secure their
own private key so you'll always need
some institution that's essentially
acting like a custodian or at least like
like facilitating you like
with these things right and so and then
there's also stuff where like
for the stable coin model to work like
usually somebody has to like hold the
deposits right and so
you know if you want interest on things
like somebody has to be like
like originating these loans and all
that kind of thing so there's there's
still a lot of like places where
traditional financial players need to
kind of be in the ecosystem
i think what things like like stellar
and crypto do is just making what's just
much more flexible it makes it
where it's like a much more even playing
field uh where
where uh you know there's just less
gatekeepers to the system like if
if if you're a new entrant like say like
someone sets up like a new
like user first bank like they can they
can easily compete with these like old
banks
uh even though they don't have new
customers because they're kind of on the
same
uh infrastructure like the same like
meaning like the the cryptocurrency
layer right so so uh because it makes
everything interoperable it makes it
where there's like more competition
which will make it where there's more
uh where there's more benefit ultimately
for the consumers that's kind of what
it's doing
got it and then in terms of stellar as
you guys kind of build for that
world um how many people do you guys
have and kind of what is everyone
focused on right in terms of
um the different bodies of work that you
guys are are actively pursuing right now
sure yeah so we're about 80 people right
now um
and we we we're focused on like several
things i mean
we kind of have like so the entity is
stellar development foundation which was
kind of the non-profit that was set up
to
to shepherd the stellar network um and
so we do we do a few things like
we we make sure that the the core code
base keeps getting maintained and like
getting moved forward and like i said
like works on things like scalability
and all that kind of stuff
um the things and then and then we work
kind of on the policy side like you know
like weighing on things like the stable
act like you just mentioned and just
making sure that
uh legislative uh like regulators and
legislators
know uh understand what crypto is
understand what stellar is and like
you know they just need to be educated
on it for the most part
because it is this new pumpkin
technology instead of just like helping
that that that side of things
and then lastly like helping on kind of
the ecosystem side with like
with um you know uh talking to partners
and like
introducing partners to each other
facilitating connections between them
one of the things like that i mentioned
earlier is that we're making this dollar
savings app it's called vibrant
um it's mainly focused in argentina and
the idea there is that
uh you know people are seeing they
suffer like really high
inflation they can like convert their
pesos into dollars and hold them in this
app and they can
send and send it around amongst each
other and things like that so
um so efforts like that where we spend
like
trying to make stellar useful for real
people in the world
right so we have another one in in uh
between nigeria and europe there's like
a big uh
b2b payments corridor going over stellar
that we're helping foster and like
you know like contribute to so things
like that where we just we're trying to
make
this this technology like one hand we're
like building the technology but like a
big part of the organization is just
trying to make this actually useful for
people
uh which i think is it's kind of that
focus it seems a little bit neglected in
the crypto industry in general to me
it's like
people get kind of enamored with how
cool the technology is and like lose
sight of like
how do we actually make it where this is
useful for people so we spend a lot of
time on that
everyone wants to show you what shiny
thing they can do with the tech but uh
but the user doesn't necessarily care of
course uh before i let you go i always
ask the same two questions to everyone
and then you'll get to ask me one to
finish
up uh the first is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
and if you don't read a lot of books you
can say any piece of content
sure uh the most important i mean
there's a ton of really good books
uh um i don't know i mean
one of the ones that i think about a lot
is this beginning of infinity by david
deutsch
uh it's it's essentially um
it's this very positive take on on on
human progress and
knowledge essentially it's essentially
like uh there's certain
there's certain ways of structuring
things where they can kind of go
infinite like if you look at the way
like dna is for instance like it's this
cool code
that allows you to build all these kind
of different organisms and
uh there's like similar things that
happen with like like with human
language like it's like
a fixed set of letters but you can make
essentially infinite amounts of
of content with it and uh it's just it's
just a very
interesting cool book so yeah that's one
of my favorites
second question is more fun aliens are
you a believer or a non-believer
uh i don't know i go back and forth they
used to be pretty convinced that they
had to be there somewhere
the fact that we don't see them or
haven't seen them in so long
uh makes me wonder if if we are in fact
alone at least in kind of our light cone
uh but um i don't know if they are there
you know i don't know there's this other
book called three party problem or
series of this trilogy
and basically it's premises that that if
there are aliens out in the world
uh they essentially are all hiding
because if any alien civilization sees
no alien situation
it really behooves them to just destroy
that other civilizations we kind of have
to hide
uh so maybe that's what's going on too
which would be which might be really bad
for us because
we're not hiding it but but uh but yeah
so i don't know
it's it's weird that we haven't seen
them are they not here i'm definitely in
the camp of uh
we don't want them to find us we want to
find them for sure
uh you could ask me one question to wrap
up what do you got for me were you a
question yeah
well so yeah what what is what's the
most interesting thing that you've seen
in the last year
yeah i mean i think the easy answer is
bitcoin right just in terms of like that
that kind of has the
capture the hearts and minds of not only
the retail side and kind of the everyday
person
uh but also the institution uh but
i changed a little bit in terms of i had
a guy who recently come on the podcast
he's
from canada uh he literally spent i
don't know he's like 32 years old or so
he spent the
last 10 12 years of his life uh laying
tile
doing construction kind of just very you
know manual type
what i would consider like the everyday
person type jobs
um and he i brought him on the podcast
because he basically was like look
you know in 2016 or 17 he went over to a
buddy's house they were all drinking
some beers watching sports
uh and usually they're talking about
their fantasy football teams and all
this nonsense
and somebody says something about crypto
and he was like oh you can get rich
there cool like you know how do i get an
account and what do i buy
right you know kind of the classic story
and he said what that set him off on
though over the last three or four years
was basically
went down the rabbit hole he started to
learn about what is money you know
financial
ins uh infrastructure kind of monetary
policy
um all the financial inclusion stuff
like just all the things that i think
once you've spent a lot of time looking
at this stuff you're like hey this
stuff's important and i wish no more
people knew about it
yeah uh and so he sent this one line to
me that was just like really powerful he
was like
i'm not trying to take over the world
i'm just trying to provide a better life
for my family
and i think that like we always forget
because it's so cool to talk about you
know
jp morgan's doing this or you know uh
this exchange just popped up and they're
gonna take down the new york stock
exchange or you know this network's
gonna take out visa and like
sure a lot of that is going to happen
but we kind of forget about like that
everyday person who literally is just
like
i now feel better educated and he's even
as far as i said like if all this fails
and i lose all my money
uh i still feel better off because i got
educated during this process and so
to me like we're now reaching the point
where like you're starting to have
enough content in this picture you're
starting to have enough information
you're starting to have enough people
where you can see like a true impact on
society
um and so it's kind of cool just to
think about like if that trend continues
you know 20 years from now 10 years from
now like
yeah actually probably your kind of
vision of like you know people in the
developing world like yeah actually a
lot of them probably do interact with
this stuff right even in the developed
world
and i think that ultimately like that's
the interesting part right
or the the part that i think we all hope
happens um
but it takes you know work every day
like you guys are doing in others to uh
to actually build a technology to make
it happen
yeah no it's pretty cool that uh i mean
one of one of the good benefits of this
whole like crypto
revolution i guess is that that people
are starting to understand a lot more
like basically it's like we're going to
pull back the curtain on how money works
like you kind of just
took it for granted beforehand but now
you're like oh wait this is this is
what's going on back here
it's uh yeah it's been pretty cool in
2020 you know they're basically
in the united states running trillion
dollar uh marketing campaigns for uh hey
we could just like edit our bank account
like oh okay
i can't do that right so like nice that
you guys can
uh where can we send people to find you
on the internet uh or find out more
about stuller
sure yeah uh i mean our website's
done.org and our reddit is pretty active
uh our stellar um i mean my twitter
account
i never really use twitter but it's
there if you wanna occasionally read
twitter
uh just at gen michaela so but yeah
awesome man well listen thank you so
much for doing this i think people will
learn a lot
and they'll have to do it again in the
future yeah great talking to you